[MUSIC PLAYING]
GILBERT STRANG: So,
I'm Gilbert Strang.
And this is about my new course
18.065 and the new textbook
Linear Algebra and
Learning from Data,
and what's in those subjects.
So there are really
two essential topics
and two supplementary, but
all very important subjects.
So if I tell you about those
four parts of mathematics that
are in the course,
that will give you
an idea if you're interested
to follow through.
So the first big subject
is linear algebra.
That subject has just surged,
exploded in importance
in practice.
What I want to focus on is
some of the best matrices, say,
symmetric matrices, orthogonal
matrices, and their relation.
Those are the stars
of linear algebra.
And the key step is
to factor a matrix
into maybe symmetric
times orthogonal matrix,
maybe orthogonal times diagonal
times orthogonal matrix--
that's a very important
factorization called
the singular value
decomposition.
That doesn't get into a lot
of linear algebra courses,
but it's so critical.
So can I speak now about
the second important topic,
which is deep learning?
So what is deep learning?
The job is to create a function.
Your inputs are, like
for driverless cars,
the input would be an
image that's a telephone
pole or a pedestrian.
And the system has to learn
to recognize which it is.
Or the inputs from
handwriting on addresses
would be a zip code.
So the system has to learn how
to recognize 0, 1, 2, 3 up to 9
from handwriting of all kinds.
Or another one is speech,
like what Siri has to do.
So my speech has to get
input and interpreted
and output by the
process of deep learning.
So it involves creating
a learning function.
The function takes
the input, the data,
and produces the output,
the meaning of that data.
And so what's the function like?
That's what mathematics
is about, functions.
So it involves matrix
multiplication.
Part of the function
is multiplying vectors
by matrices.
So that's a bunch of steps.
But if there was only that,
if it was all linear algebra,
the thing would
fail and has failed.
What makes it work now so much
that companies are investing
enormously in the technology
is that there is now
a nonlinear function, a very
simple one in the middle
between every pair of matrices.
And that nonlinear function, I
can even tell you what it is.
It's a function f,
let's call it f,
f of x is equal to
x if x is positive.
And f of x is 0
if x is negative.
So you can imagine it's graph.
It's a flat line
where it's negative.
And then it's a 45 degree
slope where it's positive.
So putting that
nonlinear function
in between the matrix
multiplications
is the way to construct
successful learning function.
But you have to
find those matrices.
I mentioned two
supporting subjects.
The first is-- optimization
would be the word.
We have to find the entries
in those matrices that
go into the learning function.
That's a crucial step.
So this is a problem
of minimizing the error
with all those matrix
entries as variables.
So this is multivariable
calculus, like 100,000.
500,000 variables, it's just
unthinkable in a basic calculus
course, but it's happening
in a company that's
working with deep learning.
And so that's the giant
calculation of deep learning.
That's what keeps
GPU's going for a week.
But it gives amazing
results that could never
have been achieved in the past.
So then the other key
subject is statistics.
And the basic
ideas of statistics
play a role here,
because when you're
multiplying a whole sequence
of matrices in deep learning,
it's very possible
for the numbers
to grow out of
sight exponentially
or to drop to zero.
And both of those are bad news
for the learning function.
So you need to keep the mean
and variance at the right spot
to keep those numbers in
the learning function,
those matrices in a good range.
So this course won't
be a statistics course,
but it will use statistics
as deep learning does.
So those are the four subjects.
Linear algebra and deep
learning, two big ones.
Optimization and
statistics, essential also.
So I hope you'll enjoy the
videos and enjoy the textbook.
And go to the OpenCourseWare
site ocw.mit.edu
for the full picture.
Beyond the videos, there
are exercises, problems,
discussion, lots more toward
making a complete presentation,
which I hope you like.